The real is
it's showing
shows
this was
fine.
I
said,
would you be interested in hearing about
is basically the story
[inaudible]
uh,
the
whole thing
just
as you were saying,
but
just
the Middle East.
Okay.
That's
okay.
Because we can give
them the composition of
each side.
One of them accepts it,
gets rid of,
he understands that the man
is the same because she,
okay.
Houston
being the case,
he more about
the history of
failed.
So he says,
if you
take me off this,
you know,
you get rid of this pain.
So
God's love taking us to taste,
you know,
to safety hospital.
The parameters of human three,
there were a whole bunch of philosophy
because he raises the idea of free
will.
Yes,
you may be a way for people like
origin in the first century,
uh,
spoke about the restoration.
Eventually we'll find a way to say,
but
the Church
and some of the 20th century people said,
look,
you tell the model versus God is love
because love sometimes has to anchor,
shout the,
the wealth to community and help
us
so much.
See someone suffering and to
people
were
secondary
school.
That's
I
said
to
come up with,
he's never been
in Wister.
Wisdom tends to focus on the
ag and now this one shows
it's a real difference
to the table.
The table,
well
show us what's called the pit.
It's happening
for some reason,
angels with the flaming sword
standing in front of the garden
because
mythical perception is mainly
a
conversation
need
to this deductive reasoning,
but again,
immediately
basically
refers to
the process and there's a whole refuge or
anthropology and psychology,
clinical psychology
over the centuries that deals with
the process by which we can purify,
which means visual.
You can see by saying,
but you can see like Phil said,
c
is deeply ingrained in the human language.
You see what I mean?
Until late June
because it was to see talks
about the eye of the soul.
The
soul is also called Moose.
Okay.
That's the eye of the soul or spirit.
Yes.
He has parents
pay attention.
Somebody films and shows.
Yes.
Why that phrase,
contemplation.
A bunch of paintings in the house
or just speak in different
places in North America,
standard places.
One was in front of the year,
he painted first of all to I
would say the sacrifice that area
it's
in some sense can control or at least
to give it your active director.
And then the gays element of this problem
is trying to make it a point in the
bay that even these day to day realities
are winning more worth paying attention
to.
Then you didn't think or even,
and so he spends 40 hours is
just somewhere on his own,
but it's an injunction to
get.
So what you think
things that are
beyond the superficial
mum communication.
So
the uh,
the colors,
you
positioning
this whole convention
without
serious
not fulfill the Ozarks division,
they close.
Then there's a huge
transfiguration in the second Sunday
we remember this man here.
He was magnificent theologian,
uh,
theologian
according to the definition
of John's Damascus.
He said,
if you pray you will be a failed login.
Now he has a theologian,
said he,
because at that time there was a lot of
interaction between these.
The list in terms of fields,
you know,
a month reading background from Calabria
came to Constantinople and begin to
share some of these scholastic,
um,
ideas from,
uh,
acquires and also from a peer
rationalistic kind of stuff.
And he
formulated the traditional
eastern view that,
um,
the grace of God is
the aim.
The acquisition of grace
is the aim of life.
And actually there is a story like
that where I come from is called the
conversation of sensor for,
with motto,
Viva,
uh,
concerning the meaning of
Christian life is about
acquiring the Holy Spirit,
the grace of God,
okay.
Um,
it's not impersonal.
It is the Holy Spirit.
Okay.
And that's what the life
of the church is hard.
Okay?
Now,
if we,
in our liturgy,
we focus,
I'll give you a
distinction between say the
traditional understanding medieval,
uh,
that,
in the Eucharist,
the priest access Christ and he says,
this is my body.
This is my blood out of
the day of the key words.
Whereas your narrow
understanding the priest,
the priest is a
real person is Christ
does this through the Holy Spirit.
But,
um,
so the,
the prayers or the risk to love
the file to send his Holy Spirit
on us along the gifts.
Okay,
so that's what that is
to divinization or feels
so that he is
the Christian.
Okay.
Otherwise,
we're kind of not realizing our potential,
not potential.
God has given us so much
and they're not using it.
When you were saying why,
why,
why do we lazy?
Because,
because why?
Because the
what's called the lure of seeing normous.
These are my peers as Saint Paul
writes is like the force of that.
It feels like
I talked about that.
Yeah,
that's fine.
No,
but I've seen him.
Youtube,
my son Ross is a big
fan.
That isn't the case.
What do I know?
It's,
I'll give you a quotation from the,
the fees,
the pesto ration or some job was awesome.
Qcs intentions,
good intentions.
You have
this beautiful place.
I realize that so many people want to
know,
should I be taking,
okay.
Another question for you
and I don't understand it.
All right,
so it's easier to go down the hill.
Fair enough.
That's that's,
and there's,
there's some delight in bitterness
of going down the hill too.
So it's not just easy shows
that there's terrible.
The trach
and the,
obviously there's a lot.
So you're here.
Here's the idea.
I had this strange idea two weeks ago,
three weeks ago,
something like that.
So I was trying to reconcile it with the
idea that I think this is more Western
Christian idea thing.
You know,
people are already human
beings on the face of Christ.
I suppose that they don't,
that seems to be a problem.
I'm going to tell him that and say
that's the question.
The question.
So here's,
here's the thought of that.
Of course that's true,
but we still have to be the work.
Guess what?
That's a very strict,
you have to think about the same time.
Maybe that's the conjunction.
We determined
that the nation is
my senior counselor,
uh,
beginning of the fourth century.
He says things like,
God cannot say you without you.
Now is that sticking point
of interpretation between
the Eastern and the Western
church?
Because it seems to me,
I mean it seems paradoxical,
both in Catholicism and the pastor.
Most of the activity seems to be
taking place on the part of God.
Well,
that's because you always want
somebody else to do with him,
right?
God,
you'll do.
Right.
Okay.
I'll say I pray to be
on the basis of hitches,
criticism up the Western church.
That's right.
There's this,
um,
where's my implement,
right?
How can I feel the have
become a human limb?
One idea that is d in
anthropology is that we have
yet to become human beings.
You know,
when policies,
behold a man that he is
the first film for me.
Right?
Then those kinds of things
around the way to do that.
You think that's what you wrote,
that's what you wrote.
That
same division tuition.
It's a very strong
synergy
versus a presence of sinners.
You
give me an African divine
and the human difference is real.
It's real.
It's what's written.
Otherwise it can't make sense of history.
Right?
Right.
Um,
as we see people suffering,
and thank God he sent me a real simple,
I know
chemotherapy and stuff like that.
Um,
that use you on insulin
except
you wouldn't think that would be
good site you would get from it.
But I guess the alternative to
that inside this to become biff,
it looks like to me
and that's not helpful.
You have,
you have to understand that
you,
I mean
that
all
the clothes,
there's a big teacher.
How much is ego?
Hello?
That tall.
He's mainly about the attempt of
human beings to self assertive.
That's called crime.
You know crime is the,
just to assert yourself over.
Other people know this is
sort of non religious people talk
about no self worth self esteem.
That's when I feel great about myself.
But if you throw the way
to say I feel bad about it,
go then say I don't care.
I can do anything right
because it's not me doing it.
I don't have to stress out what I do,
what I say,
but he's chosen
Les Pauls.
Why?
Because he loves us.
Seems a strange way to get things done.
How many people come here?
It varies.
They all trouble.
Is
the
Anglican Priest told you that the church
being the C O v stands for Christmas at
least.
Well,
right.
They're really sort of did my job.
It's this effect of life.
The church has always been
a semester and that's okay
on a Sunday,
which is not very much these figures here
on a visa.
That's the
social voice
is actually taking
leaves of assaults.
Yeah,
they did.
They uh,
what the level of the land
this is the actual
human beings don't have to be perfect.
Right.
You can go
to fictions.
Lots of papers.
That trajectory was the critical issue.
That's good.
What do you think of the revitalization
of Christianity in Russia?
It
is real.
It's going through a process of
system because when the first
four just before the full
became fashionable as well,
because the church was cursing,
people just did it for the wrong reasons.
I appreciate Christianity was a legal
is made into the state religion,
the great
general life.
So there's a lot of people
came to church for the wrong reason.
Eventually things change.
What do you think about goodness
relationship with the church?
Do you think there's anything
about that that's real?
Well,
if one were to be completely and it say,
well he's a really shrewd politician,
understands that the churches
are a real source of power.
You've got to be the right side
of the church.
Burned them all down.
Exactly.
How much did Constantine,
when he decided to kind of
see as well with the church,
he didn't make me want to
get baptized until he's dead.
He saw,
uh,
so as a matter of fact,
yes
we should talk to them all.
She was,
it was it kind of like a pagan reaction
against Christianity and against the
West Deans
was
Christianity
and also during the cultural revolution
because then we live just the full
peripheral Gushi again.
But some of
the kids have a fully out of the
mouth go hanging with Khrushchev,
promote giving him the ball and other
stuff in India and also in was helping
India.
Okay.
So you ever late fifties.
Those are falling out.
Calling the Chinese.
Didn't most of the sentence just get go?
We'll just
so
early sixties.
But somebody had done some,
actually saw
terrible things happen.
Real,
not
one Chinese priest.
There's a hole in the ground,
uh,
compress the swollen that his
head was just ticking up by
a metal backup.
I raise him
until he will just live on
the Z is not a every way
very quickly.
That's great.
Number of different translations,
Katie.
Yes,
for magazine piece together.
Go out on a creed.
He invites me and it's not just the
creative.
Now it's exactly what I think happens to
those kids that should have to schools.
That's my
Google.
My cool.
Um,
why do I know about cruising and,
but this is taking a little bit farther,
very [inaudible] here for people can,
people can hear.
It's something that people
can turn into creative.
The person who seriously seat's gone
through purification and
acceptance of the cross,
which is,
you know,
the medicine that is given to
us for purification as well.
So we put out then go gives his medicine
cause combination of two things.
It's a lot of stuff.
But in the process the person begins to
see that nothing human is from to okay.
That,
uh,
posting
this distance between the saints and
sinners is a tiny step along the saints.
Were always aware that
a number of,
of girl holding liquid,
see all of these volcanic
processes themselves,
district,
it's not the best.
Okay?
Everything's beautiful now.
Her modernism
and the soul.
Yes.
When is
he
appreciate someone was just another nurse
because
you see,
to accept the idea of God,
can we communicate?
That's what this number is gone.
Whereas Christianity presents
a paradoxical deals as
we can go all this mess.
He's cool.
He doesn't mean to make big noises.
There's a beautiful understanding
of that human to WHO's this guy here
when he
Bruce,
if you will,
in the morning,
my name is don't just so she,
because he went overboard
and he personally,
it's all nothing.
So he,
he was,
he ran it as a kid,
uh,
silence there and
he was in deep depression
and to bring him up,
we'll get a
visual.
So things,
how things
ripping the
stall.
Then
when just
jumped breach
communication was
those Jesse saying to the,
to the fireman
to
come down
because learn from the bride
and meek and humble of hot
because you have to find your medium life
by traveling on the heads of everybody
else to associates.
You'll be always somebody who's easy.
Even if you reached a pinnacle
Hitler,
right there is why many intensive.
If you give up the ego,
the pride and said
yes,
things happen.
The Real,
you know what I mean?
But that's difficult for
the full [inaudible],
the Middle East and cycling
one
these,
Jeez,
it was somebody that looked like
his profits to be,
is there another
Byzantine seems,
I mean
what we did
the
recipe
because
did
vote
rule
rule because he was I Christ
his person
or
in your
view and kind of a structure which you
have heard about vertical axis you have
to go through,
they had to rule
in the field complex,
but they will be okay.
The fact that he is a
political figure because
he is among the corporate.
Fair enough.
Okay.
And also the precursor,
those two girls,
this lady,
this boy,
we're slowly,
I think what's the point
of that very political
structure
you see that's very
personal.
The
20th century was super strongly in an
agricultural country because of that.
Most people,
we connect it to the village
Louis Parish
received
in the last couple of years
have been talking about
the episodes
as
malls to do this
think humanism room.
There's no measurable.
So it's important for the revolutionaries
to destroy traditional worldviews.
And he was a key factor in the traditional
perception after that became Verizon
too.
Because see the simple,
uh,
dozens of the basic source
of thought to themselves,
okay,
we've got [inaudible],
we've got local people,
some of them who are some not so good,
but ultimately there is truth personally.
So if suddenly he's destroyed
your rights
as a collapse of a whole view.
If people
have the education and experience in with,
uh,
all sorts of
different ideas.
But when you,
you come from a very holistic
kind of singular view of the universe,
something very big as,
okay,
well maybe like if he
allowed that sort of stuff.
So how long until the
rest of his painting,
the two,
three years
using two weeks to fly,
do we use to cover their faces?
The Majesty of God
cannot
represents class
for adventures
outside.
You've got the hospital
for different views
there.
Yes.
No,
this is why.
No.
Okay.
Waters,
right.
The flood for capitalism
simple.
The
brief,
first of all,
he to do a little bit
more just
because
his death and resurrection of Christ
die
most
sick
and symbol of peace.
It's interesting that it must be so
Asian used use three.
They use
symbols here because this is
the beginning of the pricing.
The peace.
He is piece,
uh,
is Christ the team from an
ancient Christian,
the Holy Spirit.
Why do you think,
how do you explain the fact that some
of the people don't step away from the
church
because the people who were getting all
three,
why?
Why is that
you think?
I mean everything you told me,
he said,
look,
I'll give you
just,
it's sort of
in the first 300 years,
people
love
these people can,
we would pull up
something has to change
to tell you everything.
Unfortunately,
it's
difficult to live the life when
things are okay because that forces,
it forces us down.
When you have really,
really sensitive to mobilize
to fall,
there's a rush.
The transverse like this
collapse the peasant,
we get the juice
that um,
it's difficult circumstances that people
really know where they're in anguish.
The matter of fact today
people come because they
know people can be an English
movies and stuff like that.
Take my attention.
It's like,
well,
one of the things that
struck me because you know,
after people
waste their life worth
something like
this,
most of the spots always,
always the same thing.
We never talked,
especially
something about a seeking sad,
I think it is.
They don't think each
cares,
they have
be infectious.
We need people to communicate
the basics because
you cannot understand
what I'm talking about.
The one on
maybe
because
they got to get back to that babysits
my children.
Okay.
Because
he's a good representative of very smart,
a CP
can play.
We can sit back and see
works
for 64
we were talking about
rural job assistance.
No,
no.
Computational systems
cannot do complex things.
Fire this roof.
It's not possible.
So yay.
I system network systems.
We don't know what
we're talking about.
The funding,
different quality architecture
can be facing store growth,
which is also something
is
specific.
So
what?
Harrison Harrison,
because
African students on Europe,
I said it was forced European migrants.
It's a calming force.
Interpret everything under a particular
rubric and disciplines as a consequence.
Water.